[Music]
my name is Daniel August
and I am a MLK visiting assistant
professor here at MIT Stone School of
Management and also
I am a tenure track assistant professor
uh and the department of Sociology
at Florida Atlantic University I study
barriers to entrepreneurship development
and success in order for me to inform
policies that uh
create Pro mode
shared economic prosperity and economic
Justice due to historical under
investment and law wealth Endowment in
Black communities black Americans are
less likely to be business owners
and those who do their businesses are
more likely to fail
and are less prosperous less profitable
compared to why on businesses extreme
wealth and economic inequality are
particularly harmful for
entrepreneurship and Innovations and
part of it is because as a society
advances right toward greater
industrialization the locus of
innovation changes reducing
inequality is unlocking the society's
Innovative entrepreneurial potential
thereby
ensuring the survival of
the capitalist mode of production
that was part of Martin Luther King was
to really giving people
a chance at life allowing people to
fully participate with dignity in
society